bonjour bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de parlement hebdo en compagnie de
michaël szames est ce mon jour où
michael acquis at il eu dans l'actualité
politique et parlementaire cette semaine
c'est ce que nous allons voir en 45
minutes avec d'abord l'offensive de
l'ump contre les primaires socialistes
un gigantesque fichage politique un
problème grave
les dirigeants de la majorité n'ont pas
de mots assez durs paranoïa sans
fondement répondre les socialistes
le texte sur la réforme de la justice
est arrivé cette semaine devant les
députés au programme des jurys
populaires au tribunal correctionnel et
de nouveaux aménagements dans la justice
des mineurs réforme populiste dit
l'opposition
enfin la france règle son pas sur celui
des américains en afghanistan les deux
pays ont annoncé un retrait progressif
du pays
un quart des soldats américains
devraient être partis d'ici l'été 2012
retrait français en parallèle une
annonce plutôt bien accueilli on y
revient avec nous pour partager cette
émission fabienne keller bonjour
sénatrice ump du bas rhin
bonjour ancien maire de strasbourg
aujourd'hui conseillère municipale de
cette ville
vous êtes connu pour votre franc-parler
d'ailleurs au moment des élections
cantonales il ya quelques mois vous avez
été l'une des premières à dire tout haut
qu'il fallait pourquoi pas voter pour la
gauche au deuxième tour au cas de
problème avec le front national
notamment
et puis cette semaine vous êtes fait un
ennemi au sein du gouvernement la
personne de françois baroin et demi
c'est un peu fort d'accor bon un
adversaire du jour alors on va dire que
c'était jeudi soir lors de l'examen du
projet de loi de finances rectificative
ou vous avez à l'image vous avez proposé
un amendement qui permet d'affecter des
fonds non utilisés pour le rsa à la
création d'emplois aidés pour
l'éducation nationale 200 millions
d'euros au total
voilà la suite
nous avons été battus et c'est
l'amendement de fabienne keller qui a
reçu un avis favorable de la commission
et il est de mon devoir de le dire et
pour compenser la dotation budgétaire
des 200 millions on sera obligé de faire
des déficits et c'est du structurel donc
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui n'est
pas à notre portée
aujourd'hui vous avez entendu françois
baroin vous allez est responsable d'un
trou de 200 millions d'euros
supplémentaires
avec ces emplois aidés vous lui répondez
quoi je suis une explication de quoi
s'agit-il c'est le fond hirsch
c'était pour le rsa activité c'est à
dire pour accompagner des personnes loin
de l'emploi à trouver un emploi
intermédiaire ce fonds est très sous
utilisé ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que dans la réponse à la crise
l'accompagnement des personnes éloignées
de l'emploi n'a pas eu le succès
escompté
donc je propose sur ce qui représentait
1 milliards fin 2010 de prendre une 5
milliards non utilisés 1 milliard non
utilisés fin 2010 qui a été en partie
réemployer par l'état déjà en 2011 et la
somme restante de l'ordre de 300
millions à la fin de cette année l'idée
c'est prendre une partie de cette somme
et de la fléchés vers les emplois aidés
dans l'éducation nationale par exemple
par exemple les directeurs d'école qui
sont tout seuls a dirigé des grands
établissements plusieurs centaines
d'enfants
il y a des contrats d'accompagnement à
l'emploi qui leur sont mis à disposition
ceux-ci baisse en nombre très fortement
à la rentrée ça mais les directeurs
d'école en grande difficulté au moment
où il faut bien le dire le un sur deux
est appliqué et donc il ya plutôt moins
de personnel dans les établissements
qu'on prenne bien ses 200 millions
réservés à quoi ça n'a pas été un geste
certes il vous nous pouvoir prospérer
donc de manière à permettre la
prolongation la pérennisation de ces
emplois dans les écoles pour aider les
directions et ce n'est pas 200 millions
mais 50 sur lesquels un accord avait
presque été trouvé avec le ministre
quand il a demandé une pause dans les
débats et il ne reviendra que quatre
heures plus tard au moment du vote
finalement toute la polémique qui a eu
autour de marc hein
il ya quelques semaines n'a servi à rien
l'ump avait dit que martin hirsch avait
commis des erreurs dans sa gestion
finalement on voit bien qu'il restait
beaucoup d'argent que l'état a utilisé
l'argent à autre chose finalement
alors en fait cet argent si vous voulez
est venu en moindre charge pour l'état
c'est à dire ce fonds qui est donné aux
titulaires du rsa activité est alimenté
par la taxe spéciale qu'à créer martin
hirsch et une dotation de l'état
celle ci avait été minimisé ces de bonne
gestion mais le sujet reste entier
comment accompagner les personnes en
difficultés à retrouver un emploi
et s'agissant d'éducation nationale cela
croise une priorité nationale qui est
réaffirmée qui vient d'être réaffirmée
mardi par le président de la république
dans l'aveyron donc c'est bien à la fois
avoir un objectif d'accompagnement des
plus fragiles mais aussi remplir une
mission essentielle qui sera sûrement
d'ailleurs au coeur de la campagne vous
avez élan sénateurs et oui pas mal de
sénateurs ump
beaucoup de ces deux sénateurs
centristes et de gauche contre le
gouvernement regardez favorablement
voilà alors il est clair que c'est une
dépense
il est clair que nous avons de fortes
contraintes budgétaires et qu'il faut
être extrêmement rigoureux mais dans
cette ambiance générale de grande
rigueur financière
il est important de marquer des
priorités donc si on est le retour à
l'emploi c'est priori si on résume vous
avez fait des heureux dans l'éducation
nationale et un ministre un peu ronchon
qu'on l'a vu un ministre qui je l'espère
acceptera de céder un petit peu sur un
montant plus faible pour permettre une
rentrée plus harmonieuse pour les petits
voient pas faire l'actualité de ce début
de semaine qui est marquée par
l'offensive de l'ump contre les
primaires socialistes
feu sur les primaires socialistes lancé
en début d'année sans trop de résonance
la campagne de l'ump contre le ps passe
à la vitesse supérieure les uns invoque
le secret du vote les autres le risque
de fichage des électeurs
les primaires sont un problème grave a
même déclaré le ministre de l'intérieur
le ps va porter plainte et explications
de marion lefebvre un gigantesque
fichage politique c'est ainsi que l'ump
était nonce l'organisation des primaires
socialistes pour le vote de son candidat
présidentiable
le ps va utiliser les listes électorales
puis seules les personnes qui affirment
une sympathie à l'égard du parti
socialiste pourront voter
le patron de l'ump il voit un fichage
politique des listes électorales et on
j'ai un problème c'est que concrètement
dans les villes où cela va s'organiser
nous n'avons aucune garantie que on
identifiera pas ainsi les gens qui sont
allés voter des gens qui ne sont pas
allés voter
voilà parce que dans les faits il n'y a
aucun moyen pour le parti socialiste de
le démontrer et qu'est ce qu'il ya
derrière vous l'avez rappelé un maire
socialiste constatera que telle ou telle
de ses agents à la mairie qu'à un
président d'association dont auquel il
peut donner des subventions n'aura pas
été voté par exemple eh bien vous
imaginez à la clé les pressions qui
peuvent y avoir derrière pour le
ministre de l'intérieur ces élections
primaires sont tout à fait légale mais
claude guéant demande des garanties
le parti socialiste ne doit pas utiliser
les listes d'émargement à des fins
politiques je propose aux bleus que le
parti socialiste nous dise quand il va
détruire dans quel délai très rapide et
sous quelles conditions de contrôle
et puis le débat sera clos le parti
socialiste assure lui qu'il suivra
scrupuleusement les recommandations de
la cnil
selon lui toute cette polémique n'est
que paranoïa de quoi ont-ils peur
la procédure légale que nous avons
engagée offre toutes les garanties à
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens pour que
cet acte soit un acte démocratique soit
un acte personnel soit un acte
volontaire et en n'aucun cas n'atteigne
à salies
arte l'opinion elle les primaires
socialistes se tiendront les 9 et 16
octobre prochains
les listes d'émargement pointé du doigt
elles devraient être détruites
immédiatement après fabienne keller jean
françois copé a montré des tracts
imprimés à des centaines de milliers
d'exemplaires primaires du ps fichage
politique
on n'en fait pas un peu trop du côté de
l'ump et du côté de jean françois copé
je crois pas je crois que le fait de
manipuler le fichier électoral ainsi est
très surprenant c'est vraiment de la
manipulation
oui alors que la cnil a dit qu'il n'y
avait pas de problème alors on manipule
incliné nous parce qu'on l'accueille
traite un problème très juridique elle
applique la loi
qu'en est-il sur le fond plutôt en
termes de morale
le parti socialiste va utiliser les
fichiers électoraux qui sont librement
accessibles et pointé ceux qui auront
donné 1 euros et signé la charte pour
participer à l'élection
ça permettra bien aux membres du parti
socialiste de connaître les gens
favorables dans chaque ville dans chaque
rue dans chaque quartier
c'est vraiment très très surprenant
comme méthode je sais pas si c'est
juridiquement valide mais je trouve que
c'est moralement peu admissible quand on
fait de la politique on s'adresse à tout
le monde
on vérifie pas déjà s'il est inscrit ou
pas sur le fichier électoral et
deuxièmement on ne cherche pas à cerner
ses opinions c'est le sait le secret des
urnes à strasbourg en plus où je suis
élue c'est la deuxième fois puisque ce
fichier a déjà été utilisé il y a
quelques semaines pour une consultation
sur la zone 30 sur une vitesse maximum
donc les taux de réponse par quartier
les attitudes des uns et des autres sont
connus peuvent ou que soupçonner la
justice vous avez fait quelque chose non
je pense que là c'est à nouveau plutôt
une question orale et qu' il faut
l'évoqué simplement le mettre dans le
débat c'est très surprenant se servir de
ce fichier c'est évidemment c'est quoi
la solution il est indispensable d'avoir
savoir quand même un fichier une base
électorale pour une consultation large
de tous ceux qui veulent participer ou
il ya pas vous serez comment il n'a pas
du tout besoin d'un fichier préétabli il
suffit pour le parti socialiste de faire
comme tous les grands partis
c'est de solliciter tout le monde et
ceux qui souhaitent y participer
viennent s'inscrire mais on n'utilise
pas une base de fichiers existantes pour
pointer ceux qui viennent et surtout
ceux qui ne viennent pas à cette
élection vous il ya un problème aussi
vous l'avez vu un temps de retard sur
eux sont plus moderne que vous que font
des primaires alors que vous s'est
auto-désignée un président auto désigné
il n'y a pas une question de guerre
politique et d'une campagne des fichiers
de l'ump contre le parti socialiste ce
que c'est un autre sujet la méthode les
nouvelles campagnes probablement avec
les nouvelles technologies plus ouverte
à l'échangeur discussion beaucoup plus
proche du terrain il ya clairement une
évolution des pratiques politiques
mais si on revient à l'utilisation du
fichier électoral non je pense que c'est
beaucoup plus utilitaire de la part du
parti socialiste
c'est presque un quadrillage ils
connaîtront parfaitement la situation
les rapports de force favorable et
défavorable dans l'ensemble du
territoire
c'est assez choquant en termes de
démocratie en plus franchement
par exemple on doit s'intéresser aux
étudiants même s'ils sont pas électeurs
parce qu'ils le sont dans leurs villages
d'origine enfin c'est une approche qui
est extrêmement utile eater électorale
d'un député la majorité 10 m et on
pourra quand même effectivement rayer
son nom on a le droit de faire
disparaître son nom du fichier donc ça
peut être la solution
tous ceux qui veulent ne veulent pas
apparaître peuvent disparaître
ils peuvent disparaître mais le fichier
de base et public donc l'écart entre le
fichier effacé partiellement effacé les
fichiers de départ sera connue aussi
donc tout ça c'est de l'information
franchement c'est des fichages les et
vous pensez que c'est bon pour pour des
élections démocratiques qu'on jette
comme ça le doute dès le départ sur sur
un candidat qui va être l'un des
principaux candidats de la campagne de
2012 donc qui jette le doute c'est le
parti socialiste décide d'utiliser un
outil totalement inhabituel jusque là
qui est le fichier électoral pour des
élections partisane
ça n'a jamais été la méthodologie des
des grands partis qui attendent que les
personnes fassent un geste vers eux
c'est une nouvelle manière qui est peu
peu recommandables d'aller chercher des
gens favorables
alors mardi l'assemblée
le texte sur la réforme de la justice en
ce mardi donc les députés commencent
l'examen d'un texte qui a déjà fait
l'objet de débats houleux au sénat deux
grands axes l'introduction de jurés
populaires dans les tribunaux
correctionnels et un durcissement de la
répression à l'encontre des mineurs
texte qualifié de fourre tout par
l'opposition mathilde de terriens
réconcilier les français avec la justice
la promesse de nicolas sarkozy pour
défendre cette réforme
désormais avec ce nouveau texte en
correctionnelle les trois magistrats
seront assistés de deux citoyens
assesseurs des français tirés au sort
appelés à juger dix jours des jurés
populaires qui s'exprimeront uniquement
sur des affaires d'atteintes aux
personnes passibles d'au moins cinq ans
d'emprisonnement une justice pédagogique
qui doublerait la durée des procédures
autre problème son coût la chancellerie
l'estiment à 30 millions d'euros
auxquels s'ajouteraient 20 millions si
elle se généralise pense que l'idée est
plutôt bonne et donc on a soutiendra
mais on veut avoir des assurances sur
les moyens qui seront développés pour la
faire vivre
alors que la justice n'a pas les moyens
de fonctionner correctement aujourd'hui
alors que le gouvernement n'a même pas
les moyens de financer la réforme de la
garde à vue
on nous sort en toute hâte un texte que
personne ne souhaitait aussi rapidement
sur les jurés populaires en
correctionnelle qui vont coûter très
cher mais ce qui fait vraiment débat à
l'assemblée
c'est l'autre partie du texte celle sur
les mineurs et la création d'un tribunal
correctionnel
en cas de récidive les enfants de 16 à
18 ans seront jugés par ce tribunal
la trente deuxième adaptation de
l'ordonance de 45 qui pour l'opposition
revient à baisser l'âge légal à 16 ans
le fait de dire au fond c'est plus d
enfance et des mineurs c'est presque des
majeurs parce qu'ils sont grands
ils sont plus matures camp 45e
strictement pas vrai sur trente mille
cas si son dossier serait concernée sur
cette énième réforme de la justice
nicolas sarkozy veut aller vite en
procédure d'urgence le vote devrait
avoir lieu la semaine prochaine donc
fait bien calé à la création de ce
tribunal correctionnel pour mineurs de
16 ans récidiviste c'est une bonne idée
ça veut dire effectivement quand même un
seul juge pour enfant sur trois juges on
a besoin de saints réellement alors le
débat difficile parce qu'il ya
effectivement des jeunes qui sont bien
connus des services de la justice et qui
dès 16 ans semble avoir une attitude
ressemblant pardon plutôt à celle d'un
adulte
est ce qu'il ne faut pas protéger les
enfants jusqu'à l'âge effectivement
adultes jusqu'à 18 ans moi je suis très
partagé à ce sujet il est vrai que les
juges pour enfants les connaissent bien
quand ils sont multi récidiviste il ne
perd pas beaucoup de temps avec eux
parce qu'ils les ont plusieurs fois eu
dans leur propre bureau donc créer une
justice spéciale pour ma part m'inquiète
un peu parce que cette idée qu à
l'enfant il faut donner un petit peu de
droit à l'erreur et avoir une justice
plus humaine plus adaptée qui
l'accompagnent non dans la durée
semblent mériter d'être défendus à ses
principes de la loi 45 la loi fondatrice
qui protège ce droit de revenir à
nouveau sur leur dos de carol
alors l'autre question c'est
l'instabilité des textes qui rend leur
application quand même complexe c'est
toujours plus de lois ça camoufle pas
une certaine impuissance
alors oui cette complexité ne facilite
pas la compréhension or quel est le
sujet principal c'est que les jeunes
perçoivent des mesures qui sont prises
en face de fait est que ça ait l'effet
d'exemplarité pour tous les copains et
pour tous ceux qui seraient tentés de
récidiver une nouvelle fois donc
le point sur la stabilité nécessaire du
droit pénal est clair et les mineurs
évidemment mérite un peu plus de
modération et d'attention que les
adultes pouvoir parler de la parité
fabienne keller mardi toujours un sujet
qui vous intéresse l'ump organise une
convention sur la place des femmes
notamment en politique jean françois
copé promet de faire progresser la
parité dès les prochaines élections
législatives en 2012
il faut dire que chez les députés il n'y
a que 18 % de femmes au sénat la parité
est un petit peu mieux respectée soit
22% on compte 28 femme sénatrice au
groupe ump fabienne keller vous en
faites partie
la loi impose des contraintes pour les
partis politiques mais certains
sénateurs ont une ruse pour la
contourner
ils font le choix d'une liste dissidente
qui leur permet une fois réélu de
rejoindre un groupe politique d'origine
des explications de berre un jardin
glace évidemment pourrai at il fait
juste après si aujourd'hui les femmes
sont plus présentes au sénat qu'à
l'assemblée nationale c'est grâce à la
règle du chabada c'est-à-dire
l'alternance d'hommes et de femmes sur
les listes
un dispositif qui s'applique dans tous
les départements où les sénateurs sont
élus à la proportionnelle
une règle que certains sénateurs
sortants essayent de contourner comme la
plupart du temps ce sont nos collègues
masculins qui tirent les listes et bien
la femme est en 2d donc ça mais
forcément le troisième un homme en
troisième position avec peu de chance
quelquefois des très longs et c'est
pourquoi on voit évidemment fleurir les
listes dissidentes
la raison plus de chance en étant tête
de lice sur une liste dissidente de
pouvoir être élu un véritable problème à
l'ump puisque à quelques semaines des
élections sénatoriales
les listes dissidentes ne cessent
d'apparaître en isère bernard saugey va
devoir faire face à plusieurs listes
dissidentes un combat entre hommes dans
les femmes politiques seront les
premières victimes
si vous avez des listes dissidentes avec
des hommes en tête et que la femme qui
est souvent chez moi n'est pas élu ce
sera peut-être soit
un siège de gauche soit un siège à une
liste dissidente
et à ce moment là c'est un homme qui
passe puisqu'il ya trois listes
dissidentes avec trois hommes en tête
donc effectivement ça risque d'être une
femme en moi à l'ump on reconnaît donc
la tentation de certains de jouer leur
carte en solo mais à l'heure où le parti
veut clairement s'afficher en pointe sur
la parité on entend bien combattre les
moutons noirs
ce qui est important c'est qu'à l'ump en
sus exemplaires donc il faut combattre
c'est ce que nous avons dit ce matin il
faut combattre ces listes dissidentes
mai organisé je dirais qui en fin de
compte longue pas encore accepté que les
femmes plus prendre des responsabilités
qui sont les leurs ici au sénat reste à
savoir si une fois élu ces dissidents
seront accueillis à bras ouverts ou pas
au sein du groupe ump du sénat alors
fabriqués là je vous ai vu réagir dans
ce reportage vous connaissez cette ruse
de cette liste des finances qui permet à
près de rejoindre son groupe au sénat
une fois élu bien sûr les sortants sont
majoritairement très majoritairement des
hommes et donc comme l'a expliqué ma
collègue monique papon très souvent la
deuxième place est en féminines
le troisième le celui qui est prévu pour
être troisième ne l'acceptent pas et
fait une liste à côté il ne faudrait pas
tout simplement revoir la loi sur la
parité quand on voit qu'aujourd'hui
certains ruse avec la loi non
franchement les femmes la serve de bons
prétextes mais on trouverait des
disputes des rivalités entre hommes s'il
n'y avait pas la loi sur la parité pour
justifier des listes dissidentes je
crois que c'est le jeu de la démocratie
je regrette que les femmes soient un peu
pointé comme étant celle qui empêche
d'être élu c'est sympa connaissez la
blague qui circule est au moment des
élections pour le conseiller général
quel est le féminin de conseiller
général c'est suppléante eux je crois
que très clairement il ya encore
beaucoup de marge de progrès pour les
femmes en politique c'est une blague qui
pourraient circuler aussi pour les
législatives puisque ont entendu jean
françois copé lors de cette même
convention parler des roms d'un éventuel
ticket où il y aurait comme ça un député
en campagne avec une suppléante qui
ferait ses armes
voilà et puis on leur proposerait aussi
des circonscriptions c'est le ps
actuellement qui est en place donc
voilà je fais partie de réfectionner
parti voilà les femmes sont bonnes
candidates pour les circonscriptions
désespérée mais souvent ils n'ont pas
peur parfois même elles gagnent donc
ouais c'est pour l'instant encore un
combat je crois que la place des femmes
en politique mais en cela c'est pas très
différent la situation des femmes dans
l'entreprise et des administrations
on l'a vu lors de la convention de l'ump
sur ce sujet mais j'ai envie de dire là
c'est les femmes visible et qui peuvent
se prévaloir d'un certain nombre
d'atouts et se bat alors votre part
préféré pays en 2010 une amende de 4
millions d'euros
plutôt que de respecter la parité est ce
que l'ump est misogyne
je suis pas fier de ses 4 millions
d'euros chez par conseiller c'est
largement plus que tous les autres
le bahreïn ont beaucoup moins beaucoup
moins barbie paye un peu aussi oui c'est
pas top mais franchement je suis pas
très fier de ce résultat là et les
solutions préconisées ne vous satisfont
pas non plus j'ai suis obligé les tout
ça s'est passé je suis obligé de dire
que ça reste un monde dur on ne pense
que c'est lié au rapport de force à
cette question de l'accès au pouvoir qui
est quand même très max masculine est
très violente et je crois qu'un certain
moment les femmes il ya des armes qu'on
a peut-être plus de mal que les hommes à
utiliser mais je voulais dire que
finalement là au moins c'est visible
mais et des femmes qui luttent dans leur
entreprise à des emplois subalternes et
qui ont beaucoup moins l'occasion de
revendiquer de faire valoir leur qualité
est là la situation est encore plus
difficile
c'est ce qu'on a bien vu en en débattant
mardi dernier au moins une égalité
salariale au sein des assemblées qui
n'existent pas forcé c'est vrai alors
que la règle partout ailleurs c'est
moins 28% en moyenne c'est le plafond de
verre y compris pour les femmes les plus
diplômés c'est la difficulté d'accès aux
aux responsabilités de chef de service
de directeur on ne l'expliquent pas mais
c'est le cumul de facteurs parmi
lesquels la maternité qui pénalise
fortement les femmes
elle va passer au mercredi avec un
certain cafouillage autour de la
question de la binationalité
interdire un citoyen français de
posséder une double nationalité c'est un
des projets défendus par la droite
populaire et on ce mardi le quotidien
libération révèle qu'un rapport
parlementaire en préparation préconisera
cette mesure son auteur le député ump
claude goasguen dément l'information
s'en convaincre explications de mathilde
était rien dans le rapport voté ce matin
à l'assemblée il n'est plus question de
restreindre la binationalité il faut
dire qu'au point presse de l'ump le
patron a été très clair pour lui pas
question de revenir sur ce principe
position de l'ump elle est pas des
filles moi je peux vous donner la mienne
aujourd'hui moi je suis clairement dans
l'idée que l'on maintienne le principe
de la binationalité puisque les français
qui ont double nationalité ils ont les
mêmes droits et les mêmes devoirs que
les autres français
pourtant cette mesure est réclamé par
l'ailé droite de la majorité
la droite populaire mais aussi par
marine le pen
début juin elle avait écrit aux députés
demandant la suppression de la
binationalité
finalement non le gouvernement ne
reviendra pas sur ce principe
un rétropédalage pas vraiment assumé ce
matin on a voté sur la binationalité
quelques décisions mais qu'est la
première déclaration de binationalité
comme ça envoie madame joly pourra
parler en sachant et madame le pen aussi
ça me fait plaisir
déclaration de binationalité sur les
actes d'état civil ce qui n'existe pas
aujourd'hui personne est obligée de
déclarer sa multinationalité à gauche on
accuse la droite d'investir les terres
du fn
malgré cette modification manuel valls
président de la commission s'est
désolidarisé monsieur claude goasguen a
dû reculer sur injonction de
l'elysée l'essentiel reste la mise en
cause de la binationalité
pour ceux qui à qui a la nationalité
française par voie de naturalisation
pourvoi de mariage et la mise en cause
du droit du sol
le 7 juillet l'ump organise une nouvelle
convention consacrée à l'immigration et
l'intégration
l'occasion pour le collectif de la
droite populaire de faire de nouveau
entendre sa voir alors que la seconde
claude goasguen préconise est que tout
candidat à la nationalité française par
le mariage ou par la naturalisation
renonce à son autre nationalité
ce serait une faute d'avoir deux
nationalités moi j'ai une conviction
c'est que c'est une richesse d'avoir des
français qui ont un lien avec un autre
pays dans le monde
c'est en fait un peu l'histoire de la
france l'histoire de l'accueil 7
cette qualité cette ce droit du sol qui
caractérise la france cet accueil
cette relâche se tisse une relation
aussi dans le monde qui constituent un
élément fort de l'histoire que c'est
avoir un débat sur cette question vous
inspire quoi
alors qu'il ya un débat vivant c'est un
nom mais qui est un débat le débat est
toujours bon qu'il y ait une polémique
c'est un peu dommage puisque apparemment
monsieur goasguen n'avait pas
l'intention de proposer cette cette
mesure qu'elles soient polémique on n'en
doute pas dès lors que c'est une thèse
de madame marine le pen de la droite
populaire également l'instant alors la
droite populaire semble défendre cette
thèse moi je ne la partage pas et une
nouvelle offensive de cette droite
populaire qui chaque semaine arrive avec
un nouveau dossier et une nouvelle
polémique
moi je voudrais mettre des mots là
dessus c'est clairement une richesse
d'être franco américain pourquoi ce ne
serait pas une formidable richesse
d'être franco tunisien franco-marocain
franco-sénégalais ces personnes qui à
cause de leur parcours personnel ou à
cause de l'histoire de la france à la
colonisation
la décolonisation et grâce à ces
mouvements ont créé un tissu de
relations familiales humaine avec ces
pays c'est une ouverture
c'est une richesse six sont les règles
jean françois copé l'a très clairement
rappelé les droits et les devoirs d'être
français quand on a deux nationalités on
est pleinement français on en assume les
contraintes ils ensemble d
les atouts mais c'est aussi une richesse
et vivons le simplement comme un élément
constitutif de la société française et
puis sur le sujet des personnes
concernées la plupart sont nés en france
ou marié à une personne française donc
sont clairement français il aime la
france ils ont fait le choix d'adhérer à
cette nationalité donc profitons-en
peut-être pour avoir des relations plus
fortes avec les pays où sont nés
peut-être leurs parents ou leurs grands
parents
et c'est un sujet au moment où il ya des
révolutions démocratiques dans le
maghreb et des mouvements qui démarre en
afrique noire particulièrement porter
parce que nous avons une voix et ces
binationaux ont un rôle a probablement
pas là il s'agit des binationaux mais il
pourrait s'agir aussi d'autres thèmes
qui ont été ouverts ces dernières
semaines par cette droite populaire afin
ça fait pas beaucoup ça fait pas
finalement le lit d'autres partis bon je
suis obligé de dire que c'est pas tout à
fait mon positionnement la droite
populaire pour ma part moi je fais
partie des centristes de l'ump donc nous
avons les positions beaucoup plus
ouverte et plus humaniste s'ils marquent
leur leurs convictions ils défendent
leur dîner qui se veut plus entendre que
la droite sociale en ce moment alors
peut-être que la droite populaire à des
tests plus marqué plus clivante qui font
que médiatiquement ça passe plus fort
que des thèses centrise plus équilibrée
plus médiane plus soucieuse aussi de
respecter chacun et on va parler de
l'élection présidentielle mercredi
toujours une nouvelle candidate de plus
à droite dans la course à la
présidentielle
christine boutin qui dit incarner la
droite sociale et traditionnel sera
présente en 2012 la présidente du parti
chrétien-démocrate accorde du crédit au
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy
mais pour elle il reste beaucoup à faire
il souhaite aussi relevé le défi écouter
est-ce que rien n'aurait été tentée
depuis cinq ans si il est vrai avec une
certaine détermination il a été essayé
de faire passer le cap de la
mondialisation à notre pays
de nombreuses réformes nécessaires ont
été votées mais rien de fondamental sur
les questions essentielles sans
lesquelles il est vain d'espérer un
redressement rapide
et durable de notre pays ça fait une
nouvelle candidate parmi tous les
candidats potentiels en tout cas à
droite ou au centre droit ça commence à
faire peut-être un petit peu beaucoup
sur la ligne de départ nous nous sommes
avant l'été à 11 mois de l'élection je
crois que c'est plutôt bien d'avoir un
foisonnement de candidats des
propositions des personnes qui
s'engagent aussi pour la france et qui
je l'espère s'engage un débat madame
boutin présente sa candidature à
montfermeil dont le maire est d'ailleurs
très engagés dans la rénovation dans la
transformation de sa ville je suis
obligé de dire quand même j'ai pas été
impressionné par l'action de madame
boutin dans ce domaine pendant qu'elle
faisait partie du gouvernement alors
qu'il y attendent actions et en priorité
à poursuivre auprès des plus fragiles en
france alors vous dites que c'est bien
qu'ils aient autant de candidats mais
finalement le fait qu'il y ait beaucoup
de candidats marqué à droite c'est pas
quelques pourcentages qui va manquer au
premier tour pour nicolas sarkozy lui
qui a dit qu'il ferait de ce premier
tour premier tour test finalement
franchement je pense que c'est trop tôt
pour le dire les choses sont pas
décantée ça se fera plus tôt à l'automne
je crois que c'est bien qu'on ouvre le
débat que la france s'exprime que des
échanges puissent avoir lieu pour notre
part les centristes avec jean louis
borloo notamment nous engageons des
thématiques autour de l'europe qui a
disparu du débat c'est incroyable autour
de la question des quartiers difficiles
autour de cette question tellement
important de l'écologie et de la prise
en compte mail et les contraintes nous
rattrape de l'énergie dans les choix de
développement et le modèle du
développement
prenons le temps de ce débat et puis les
choses vont se décanter il y aura moins
de candidats au départ que prévu ils
entendent en tout cas où vous êtes
plutôt jean louis borloo que nicolas
sarkozy écoutez moi je suis pour que la
majorité présidentielle organise un vrai
débat qui les choses soit ouverte et
qu'on ne s'accroche pas des sondages qui
sont une photo de l'opinion aujourd'hui
mais l'opinion va évoluer va débattre va
échanger
vous êtes favorable à une candidature de
jean-louis borloo face a dit connaître
moi je pense que oui il y a une place
pour une sensibilité centriste dans le
débat présidentiel et vous vous sentez
plus proche de cette sensibilité là j'ai
le sentiment que l'ump
vu son centre de gravité aller vers la
droite populaire qu'on évoquait à
l'instant grâce à son activisme
notamment donc et que les idées
centristes oui donc oui plutôt humaniste
mérite d'être incarné d'accord donc je
vais donc je soutiens le chemin de jean
louis borloo est sûre sur un soutien de
votre pain visite allemand et de braunau
moi parlons de sénateur également qui
vous suivent sur sept sur scène démarche
il ya pas mal de sénateurs et de députés
qui sont soucieux de retrouver des
valeurs centristes humanistes attentif à
l'autre
comment dire raisonnable aussi du point
de vue et est responsable du point de
vue de l' équilibre financier de l'état
donc dans cet équilibre pas très
communicant mais qui correspond je crois
bien à la sensibilité des français
aujourd'hui
et puis ce mercredi encore en fin de
journée l'ancien secrétaire d'état
georges tron a été mise en examen avec
son ancienne adjointe pour viols et
agressions sexuelles en réunion il a été
remis en liberté sous contrôle
judiciaire
matile de terriers c'est peu avant 15
heures qu'ils arrivent au tribunal
après deux jours et deux nuits en garde
à vue l'ancien secrétaire d'état à la
fonction publique sera présenté cette
fois ci un juge d'instruction est un
juge des libertés et de la détention
motif invoqué viols et agressions
sexuelles en réunion par personne ayant
autorité
selon une source proche du dossier
georges tron aurait exercé des pressions
sur les témoins le parquet retient alors
son placement sous contrôle judiciaire
ils demandent aussi sa mise en examen
lui qui a pourtant toujours contesté les
faits le monsieur tron conteste
absolument absolument les faits toute
relation de nature sexuelle avec les
victimes même des relations qui auraient
été consenties
la procureure demande aussi la mise en
examen de sa mère adjointe brigitte
gruel visée elle aussi par les plaintes
des deux anciennes employées municipales
de draveil
le 29 mai georges tron avait démissionné
du gouvernement
il devait donc retourner automatiquement
sur les bancs de l'assemblée mercredi
prochain et être protégé à ce moment là
par une immunité parlementaire
il ne prend effet qu'à partir du moment
où il est effectivement un
il a aussi déjà nouveau à l'assemblée
reste alors au bureau de l'assemblée de
décider de lever ou non son immunité
levée l'immunité parlementaire ça vous
semble logique dans ce genre d'affaires
ces affaires sont comment dire terrible
pour la politique mais d'un autre côté
la parole s'est libérée et je crois que
si des faits se produit depuis l'
affaire dsk et que si des faits se
produisent dans l'univers politique ou
ailleurs il est important que les
personnes que les victimes s'expriment
maintenant s'agissant du cas particulier
georges tron franchement mes juges
décideront le procureur a utilisé la
fenêtre la période dans laquelle il
n'était pas protégé par une immunité
soit de ministres soit très vite deux
parlementaires la justice je n'en doute
pas fait et sont mal à lever cette
immunité parce que pour l'instant s'il
revient l'assemblée la semaine prochaine
il l'aura franchi qu'une décision du
bureau je connais pas le dossier au
bureau décidera son âme et conscience ce
qui est clair c'est que tout cela à
discréditer encore un peu plus la
politique
moi je voudrais penser à aux centaines
de milliers d'élus locaux qui se donne
beaucoup de mal qui n'ont rien à voir
avec ces histoires dont peut-être qu'il
faut pas trop généralisée par contre il
est vraiment important que les personnes
qui ont subi des pressions surtout sur
une par une personne qui a un ascendant
a une responsabilité hiérarchique
s'exprime la loi du silence ne doit plus
être la règle
au passage je dis la france annonce une
sortie de ses troupes d'afghanistan
la fin de l'engagement français est
amorcé ce sera un retrait progressif
comme les états unis pour le premier
ministre et le ministre de la défense ce
retrait n'est pas une surprise
il s'inscrit dans le cadre d'une
transmission des pouvoirs à l'armée
afghane la france compte près de 4000
soldats sur place vers au jardin gas
10000 jrs devrait être de retour sur le
sol américain bourg noël c'est donc un
retrait massif et rapide que barack
obama a promis après avoir doublé puis
triplé le contingent en afghanistan
depuis son arrivée le président a
ordonné le rapatriement d'ici 2012 d'un
tiers des forces déployées sur place
soit 33 mille hommes malgré les avis
contraires de ses généraux
le président a tranché estimant qu'
al-qaïda et durablement affaiblie alors
qu'aiden la pression sur al-qaïda est à
son plus haut depuis le 11 septembre
avec les pakistanais
nous avons tué plus de la moitié des
dirigeants d'al qaïda le chef de l'état
afghan hamid karzaï a salué aujourd'hui
l'annoncent comme une bonne mesure pour
les américains comme pour l'afghanistan
quant aux talibans dont l'insurrection a
gagné du terrain et qui ont entamé des
négociations avec les états unis
ils réclament toujours un retrait total
jugeant lé annonce symbolique et
insuffisante
les alliés engagés sur place auprès de
washington ont affiché leur accord avec
cette décision
ainsi la france a indiqué qu'elle
procéderait à un retrait progressif de
ses hommes
les résultats des troupes sur le terrain
d'une part l'élimination de ben laden
d'autre part la reprise d'un dialogue
à l'intérieur des forces paul entre les
forces politiques à vaughan laisse à
penser qu'avec le travail de
pacification assurée par les troupes
on peut alléger le dispositif mille
soldats français devrait donc quitter le
sol afghan d'ici un an
le calendrier président du retrait n'est
pas fixée pour l'instant
alors ce vendredi le président de la
république l'a clairement dit plusieurs
centaines de soldats français partiront
d'afghanistan d'ici la fin de mai 2011
il était temps de partir fabienne keller
dix ans de guerre sous mandat de l'onu
bien sûr un pays miné par le trafic de
drogue un gouvernement autour d'hamid
karzaï pas vraiment légitime et enfin
qui semble être dans un double jeu
je crois que malheureusement on n'a pas
résolu les problèmes sur place
malheureusement c'est un pays encore
extrêmement fragile et pas structuré en
termes institutionnels raison d'en
partir alors mais je dois dire que
malheureusement les interventions des
forces alliées mandaté à nouveau par les
nations unies n'ont pas permis de
rétablir un état de son sans garantie
que les talibans parents ne revienne au
pouvoir
absolument nous n'avons pas été la
communauté internationale n'a pas été en
mesure de rétablir une justice une
police une arme et un gouvernement de
nature à protéger les libertés
essentielles
nous étions sur place aussi pour lutter
contre al qaïda et pour faire la chasse
aux talibans sur al-qaïda ont obtenu
quelques succès sur les talibans
absolument aucun c'est l'avenir qui nous
dira si ses 10 ans de présence ont
permis d'aller dans le bon sens
beaucoup aussi de réaction pas toujours
positive à l'égard de la présence des
forces internationales donc un bilan
très mitigé et du temps qui sera
analysée maintenant cela doit nous
encourager
s'agissant de la libye à poursuivre une
guerre forte et rapide mars qu on voit
aussi les faits d' enlisement d'une
présence censée maintenir la paix mais
une intervention pas suffisante pour
épauler un état fort pour qu'il puisse
se décidera sur la question de 12
juilletth absolue 18 aces quatre mois
sion donc les servants d'être votée est
obligatoire je participerai à ce débat
parce que je pense que en plus en libye
un côté de la tunisie pas loin de
l'algérie du maroc nous avons une
responsabilité particulière est
clairement kadhafi menace toute la zone
s'il survit enfin s'ils sont son
autorité peut continuer à prospérer
d'une manière ou d'une autre cela mettra
une cloche sous des mouvements
démocratiques à peine émergents donc il
ya clairement une intervention immédiate
après après des mouvements du mois de
janvier qu'il s'agit de concrétiser il
s'agit d'épauler ses démocraties à peine
émergentes
on a un vrai problème aussi avec ce
qu'on appelle les opex les opérations
extérieures
finalement un manque de moyens longue de
moyens humains et financiers pour nos
armées qui sont un petit peu partout
dans le monde
enfin on a pris la mesure des
engagements de l'armée afghanistan côte
d'ivoire libye aujourd'hui avec une des
forces maritimes la marine nationale
absolument remarquable mais presque en
limite sur un certain nombre de moyens
et d'équipage
une force qui doit peut-être être
calibrée recalibré par rapport à ses
objectifs opérationnels
parce que n'y at il pas de d'engagement
plus exemplaire que celui qui consiste à
défendre la démocratie et les missions
de l'onu dans le monde devrait rappeler
aussi qu'en afghanistan 60 français ont
laissé leurs vins
moi j'étais en alsace à sélestat au
retour d'une unité de gendarmerie qui
revenaient d'afghanistan
je veux dire que c'est très
impressionnant d'entendre
les soldats leurs lieutenants leur
capitaine parler delà de ce qu'ils ont
vécu des risques permanents oui et des
dangers de toutes ces sous-munitions qui
sont sur le territoire et d'une vraie
des formes ce qu'a mis en place enfin un
système qu'elle mis en place les afghans
contre les forces de l'onu allez on
continue avec jeudi encore la polémique
qui monte autour des épreuves du bac est
un exercice de maths s'est retrouvé sur
internet la veille de l'examen
luc chatel a décidé de ne pas faire
repasser l'épreuve d'autres fuites
auraient pu avoir lieu dans d'autres
matières mates yale de bélanger deux
personnes ont été placées en garde à vue
ce soir deux jeunes majeurs soupçonnés
d'être à l'origine des fuites
le ministère de l'éducation nationale a
ordonné par ailleurs une enquête
administrative sur d'autres rumeurs de
fraudes et concernant l'épreuve de
mathématiques luc chatel s'est voulu
rassurant ce matin
l'exercice qui a fuité ne sera pas
comptabilisé
je suis le garant de l'égalité de tous
les candidats face à cet examen
il y avait rupture d'égalité j'ai pris
la décision qui permettait de léser le
moins possible les candidats une
décision qui ne satisfait pourtant pas
tout le monde un parent d'élève a déposé
sans succès ce matin un recours devant
le conseil d'état
beaucoup demandent que l'épreuve soit
noté normalement une très grande
majorité des enfants nous ont fait part
de de la réussite qu'ils avaient eues
sur cet exercice
c'est vrai que c'est un petit peu punir
l'ensemble des élèves pour une poignée
de personnes mal attentionnées
l'éducation nationale de son côté veut
calmer la polémique
un nouveau barème précis de l'épreuve a
été diffusée aujourd'hui alors à
parvenir sur le débat fallait-il ou non
annulé cette épreuve la refaire et c'est
le nombre de points mais peut-être plus
largement est ce que c'est l'occasion de
remettre un petit peu en cause ce bac
sacro-saint en france et qui est une
sorte d'exception française est ce qu'il
faut par contre le continue vous qui
connaissez bien
c'est ce domaine de l'éducation alors il
est probable qu'un contrôle tout au long
des études seraient moins ambitieux gêne
pour les enfants est moins stressant et
il serait un peu plus juste aussi parce
que dans la durée on vise plus juste on
évalue plus plus sereinement
à l'inversé les français tiennent à ce
bac donc comment trouver un équilibre
entre un bac bien harmonisé au niveau
national et puis quand même une prise en
compte
de l'effort dans la durée et c'est bien
dans la durée qu'on souhaite former
accompagner les jeunes il ya visiblement
un vraiment dans la sécurisation des
copies avant avant les épreuves de
chaque année maintenant il y à des
fuites
ouais mais il ya les nouvelles télés
village et aussi avant il fallait
prendre un papier le photocopier c'était
compliqué maintenant lui qui fait même
plus de bruit et l'exercice est copiée
j'aurais quand même dire que c'est un
peu dur c'est vraiment dur pour les
élèves de terminale qui ont suivi cette
épreuve parce que le premier exercice de
maths en général est plutôt accessible
donc il peut être assez content
encouragé à poursuivre et c'est que ce
soit le premier qui qu'ils soient
annulés c'est un peu anxiogène au moment
où ils ont encore des épreuves à passer
dans les jours qui viennent
donc je crois que le ministre a pris une
décision rapide pour les sécuriser
s'engageant à ne pas refaire les preuves
mais on peut se poser la question à
l'air de l'instantané si cette formule
de même bac pour tout le monde sur un
grand territoire avec donc des minières
j'aurais ya un côté militaire puisqu'on
vous oubliez que dans ce si on fait une
épreuve pour chaque lycée par exemple
chaque terminal il ya un an qui note
plus ou moins sévèrement plus ou moins
rassurant mais avoriaz vd des devoirs
par grandes régions à éviter d'avoir un
pépin je ressens soit 5000 jeunes en
même temps et ça permettait
éventuellement de refaire une épreuve en
cas de besoin ou de faire l'épreuve de
secours donc un immense dispositif avec
beaucoup de gens et une seule faille ou
un seul qui souhaite apparemment c'était
volontaire désorganisé le bac peut le
faire bien qu'elle est est ce que vous
connaissez le quadrille le cadre et la
danse du quadrille la danse du quadrille
exactement que c'est une danse de bal et
de salon qui était utilisée souvent au
19e siècle mais cette semaine c'était la
fête de la musique et je vous propose de
découvrir ces quelques images
regardez c'était dans le jardin du
luxembourg le président du sénat gérard
larcher très bon style très bon danseur
vous allez le voir sur ces images des
caisses de l'instant voyez marie luce
penchard ministre de l'outre-mer et
voilà je vous laisse découvrir en images
et en musique
vous l'aviez déjà vu comme ça le gêne et
non j'ai qu'un regret c'est pas avoir
repéré cette fête bien sympa et d'y
avoir participé j'adore danser ça s'est
passé pas très lointain du sénat donc
dans les jardins hommage du luxembourg
pour fêter la fête de la musique vous
avez fait car les choses ou pour la fête
de la musique à fragments l'automne est
bien j'étais 11 séances toute l'année
pour défendre tournoi pour les employés
donc je me dis que j'ai relâché n'y
étais pas donc je ne suis sorti que à
une heure du matin à la fin de séance et
il pleuve yacht est donc il n'y avait
plus beaucoup de musiciens
à mon grand regret parce que je trouve
que c'est une très belle soirée
c'est l'occasion de rencontre d'animaux
relaxe dans les rues mais en tout cas on
a une confirmation gérard larcher à une
reconversion toute trouvée s'ils le
souhaitent
voilà pas pour lui j'espère le garder
comme président merci eric heller
merci d'abord être avec nous pas nous et
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine même
lieu même heure au revoir